[Musica]
ansia panico e paura
queste tre parole mi sono rimbalzate in
questi giorni nella testa come delle
palline in un flipper impazzito
ho fatto 30 esami all'università senza
perdere una sola notte di sonno
eppure oggi vi devo parlare di
creatività e della mia arte è la paura
del giudizio è una caratteristica
esclusiva mente umana e io lo sono io
sono monica de mattei dipingo pesci
alexa ti piacciono i pesci invece il mio
pesce preferito è il pon acantus
imperator è il primo pesce che ho
dipinto nel 2005 quando ho fatto una
collezione di oblò con visioni
sottomarine realistiche nel 2016
ho passato un anno di quelli che ti
segnano la vita ho avuto esperienze
positive e negative sono successe un
sacco di cose come al solito le cose
succedono tutte insieme ma mai per caso
e quell'anno ho incontrato una visual
coach che mi ha fatto dipingere una
farfalla l'ha fatta dipingere nelle sue
quattro fasi di metamorfosi dall'uomo al
bruco alla pupa all'adulto e nel
dipingere questa questa farfalla
avvenuto anche la mia trasformazione lei
per la prima volta mi ha chiesto di
dipingere non una cosa realistica uguale
a una foto mi ha chiesto di dipingere
quello che sentivo dentro come avrei
voluto che fosse una farfalla dopo
questa farfalla il primo quadro è stato
subito un pesce e avendo trovato la mia
vena creativa
non mi sono più fermata in questi quasi
quattro anni ho dipinto circa 200
soggetti della mia fantasia e una
citazione che mi piace sempre molto
ricordare di picasso è che a 12 anni
dipingevo come raffaello e ci ho messo
tutta la vita a imparare a dipingere
come un bambino
io adoro dipingere le mie creature
fantasiose e la maggior parte delle
persone quando vede questa grande
quantità di quadri tutti con lo stesso
soggetto a un sacco di domande c'è la
pole position delle domande perché i
pesci poi mi chiedono sei del segno dei
pesci
oppure naturalmente i pesci non li mangi
io sono bilancia e sono pesce italiana
non mangiano carta mangio solamente
pesci
sono incuriositi a riguardo delle mie
scelte dei colori e piace molto spesso
dare delle interpretazioni
se faccio dei quadri che hanno dei
colori predominanti accesi come il rosso
mi chiedono se li ho fatti in un periodo
in cui ero innamorata e se uso il verde
pensano che cercassi la serenità
oppure quando la predominanza ed i viola
o di lilla suppongono che stessi facendo
una ricerca spirituale e spicca me
sembra di usarli sempre tutti insieme i
colori
un'altra domanda che mi incuriosisce
molto
è quanto tempo ci metto a fare un quadro
a questa domanda ci sono tantissime
risposte quelle più logiche sono legate
alla dimensione alla quantità di
soggetti che devo che devo inserire ma
la verità è che il tempo di
realizzazione di un'opera dipende da
come il mio stato d'animo
io posso iniziare un quadro e finirlo
nell'arco di una giornata perché sono
ispirata perché sono serena perché sono
felice è perché ho fatto esattamente
quello che volevo fare
mentre ci sono altri quadri che ci metto
dei mesi li faccio li riguardo li
appendo lirico loro ci vado sopra
diventano materici da tante volte
ripasso sopra il colore e li trasforma
fino a quando non sono soddisfatta di
quello che volevo fare
quindi la domanda di quanto tempo ci ci
metto a volte mi fa pensare che le
persone magari la colleghino al fatto
che
si possa dare un valore economico a
un'opera d'arte in base al tempo di
realizzazione
e questo secondo me è veramente
impossibile
basti pensare ai tagli di fontana la
curiosità e il giudizio sono veramente
caratteristiche umane ed è molto
importante che noi impariamo a valutarle
e prendere il lato positivo di queste
due nostre caratteristiche
ciò anche sono curiosa e chiedo quasi a
tutti qual è il quadro preferito fra
tutti i miei e sono molto felice quando
vedo che tutti scelgono un quadro
diverso
questo significa che il mio intento di
rendere ogni mia opera unica e personale
sono riuscita a realizzarlo
una cosa che però quasi nessuno si
accorge e che i miei pesci solo senza la
bocca e devo dire che non me ne ero
accorta nemmeno io me lo ha fatto notare
un architetto molto attento e mi ha
fatto per riflettere sul fatto che io
pongo molta attenzione agli occhi perché
è evidente che per me la parola non è il
mio mezzo di comunicazione
io mi esprimo attraverso l'arte la
creatività è l'intelligenza che si
diverte e io mi diverto tantissimo a
dipingere i miei quadri
da cosa che anche attraverso la mia arte
ho capito è che appunto non bisogna
avere paura del giudizio
gli unici sono costruttivi ci aiutano ad
evolvere è importante ascoltare le
valutazioni e giudizi di ognuno tanto
l'arte è soggettiva un quadro può
piacere o non piacere
non importa la cosa importante è avere
la propria personalità e questo credo di
averlo espresso particolarmente nella
mia collezione un pesce fuor d'acqua e o
in questo ciclo o fisicamente estratto i
pesci dalla tavola li ho liberati perché
per me essere un pesce fuor d'acqua è
una liberazione non deve essere per
forza legato a un concetto di sentirsi
inadeguati sentirsi in un luogo che
qualcuno ha stabilito essere sbagliato
per noi essere un pesce fuor d'acqua
per me significa essere creativa essere
originale e avere sempre qualcosa da
dire di diverso e di personale io
infatti penso che l'arte sia un
potentissimo mezzo di comunicazione e
come mi hanno descritto
nell'introduzione io sono
un'imprenditrice o una agenzia di eventi
e creo progetti per le aziende che
utilizzano l'arte come mezzo di
comunicazione
essendo io così monotematica non potevo
non essere sensibile al tema della
plastica nei mari però volevo trattare
questo tema in un modo positivo e
costruttivo
volevo prendere dalla plastica il suo
valore migliore
il fatto di essere in distrutto
di bile e quindi ho deciso di
utilizzarla e farla diventare parte
delle mie opere d'arte
ho creato questo progetto che è anche un
mio ciclo si chiama plastic fish io
raccolgo le bottiglie di plastica le
tagliole brucio le modello l'en chiodo
le faccio diventare le squame delle mie
opere e quindi vi chiedo di aiutarmi a
raccogliere le bottiglie di plastica e a
farle diventare parte di opere d'arte
che resteranno nel tempo più delle tele
dei grandi maestri
grazie
[Applauso]